learn how to use stable diffusion to
create art and images in this full
course you will learn how to train your
own model how to use control net and how
to use stable diffusion's API endpoint
this course focuses on teaching you how
to use stable diffusion as a tool
instead of going into the technical
details it's a perfect starting place
for beginners Lin Zhang developed this
course she is a software engineer at
Salesforce and a free code Camp team
member let's get started hey everyone
I'm Lane I'm a software engineer and a
hobbyist game developer and today I'm
bringing you a new Hands-On coding
tutorial
in today's video we're gonna generate
art using an AI tool called stable
diffusion
if you look up the definition of stable
it is a deep learning text to image
model released in 2022 based on
diffusion techniques
in today's video we're gonna focus on
teaching you how to use stable diffusion
as a tool instead of going into the
technical details to understand some big
terms like variational autoencoders or
embeddings or diffusion techniques you
will have to have some machine learning
background and also do some research on
your own
there is some Hardware requirement for
this course you will need to have access
to some form of GPU either local or AWS
or some other Cloud hosted ones to try
out the course material
because it will be hosting our own
instance of stable diffusion
it's very unfortunate uh this will not
work for the free GPU environment that
Google collab provides because Google
collab bans the multiplication from
running in their notebooks
don't worry if you really don't have
access to any GPU power
it is still possible for you to try out
some web hosted stable division
instances I will include an extra part
at the end of this video to show you how
you can access these cloud-hosted
environments
so that said let's take a look at the
topics we're going to cover today the
first one will be how to use stable
diffusion how to set it up locally the
second how to train your own model for a
specific character or art style we call
these Laura models Third how to use
control net a popular stable diffusion
plugin and last but not least how to use
stable diffusion's API endpoint
at the end of the course you should have
no problem generating images that look
like these
pretty impressive huh
all right I know you're excited but
before we get started uh disclaimer we
respect the work of artists and
acknowledge that AI generated art using
stable diffusion is a tool that could be
used to enhance creativity but it does
not replace the value of human
creativity
all right and now we are ready to get
started
let's start by installing stable
diffusion on your local
we're gonna go to the skithub repository
and install them based on the
instructions
I'm gonna be installing on a Linux
machine
the installation process may take a
while so be patient
all right and now everything has been
installed
let's open the directory that we just
installed and inspect the contents
we can see that there is a subdirectory
for the models
the instructions under model stable
diffusion says to put stable diffusion
checkpoint models here so let's go and
download some models
the website that we are going to be
using is Civic AI
Civic AI is a model hosting site and we
can see there are lots of models
uploaded by different users
one of the models that I like to use is
called counterfeit
it generates anime-like images
when we open the model page we can see
some sample images generated by the
model
and we take a look at the files these
are the uploaded models
it looks like the maintainer of this
model regularly updates the versions so
we can go to their links to see the
updated versions
we see a bunch of files adding dot safe
tensors and these will be the models
that we're going to use we also see a
DOT va.pt this is a variational
autoencoder model that will make our
images look better more saturated and
clearer we're gonna download models and
put the checkpoint models in model slash
stable diffusion and the vaee model
slash vaes if the vae folder doesn't
exist just create a VA folder
once we have downloaded our checkpoint
and vae models we're almost ready to
launch the web UI
we can customize some settings in web UI
user.shell
when you open this file the export
command line arcs should be an empty
string for my command line arguments I
have configured to share this means that
when I launch the web UI it says
localhost it will also expose a public
accessible URL this way my friends can
access my locally hosted web UI via this
public URL
here's a part that I didn't capture in
the video for the web UI to use the VA
by default you have to set the VA path
in web UI user.shell here is my web UI
user.shop it has lots of customizations
now it's finally time to start the web
UI using web ui.shell if you're a
Windows user you will run web ui.bat
starting the web UI is going to take
some time so I will speed up the video
from the log lines you can see that our
vae has been loaded
and we have both a localhost URL and a
public URL
let's try out the public URL
so this is what the web user interface
looks like
we can see a big text box here for
entering prompts to generate an image
all right let's start typing something
I'm gonna ask for a girl with a short
brow hair and green eyes and with a
simple background
let's hit the big generate button and
it's going to take a few minutes
I'm gonna speed up the video for you
alright it looks like we thought our
girl with a short brow hair and a green
eyes on a simple background
all right so our tax prompt in the form
of a long strand worked
it is also possible to use keywords or
text
we're gonna look at this website that
has some reference tags for example you
can see like girl long hair short hair
skirt
most of the checkpoint models we're
using for stable diffusion are indeed
trained on these tags so the models will
have no problem parsing those keywords
let's rewrite our prompt using those
keywords
foreign
our prompt we're gonna look at some of
the parameters you can see when you
hover over the parameters there's some
explanation text
we're going to increase the batch size
so that we get multiple images from one
generation
and the turn on restore phase
you can learn about these parameters by
hovering over them and reading about
them yourself
and indeed we got some girls with brown
hair green eyes round glasses on a very
simple background
I actually want stable diffusion to help
generate some images of Lydia our
protagonist from learntical RPG who has
brown hair green eyes round glasses and
also braids her hair between the back of
her head
so we're gonna add braided hair to see
if the AI will pick it up
if you're like me you might notice that
the background is a little bit too green
and
we can adjust that we just need to put
in a negative prompt for our green
background and we will see different
color backgrounds
the good news is that the backgrounds
are no longer green however the braided
hair isn't exactly in the direction that
we want it to be so I guess we should
adjust that in the prompt
I feel like it's also a good time to
experiment with a different sampling
method
different Samplers can produce a pretty
different art styles and you can see
some comparison images if you do a
Google search I will also try to link to
some in my article
looks like the first and second picture
do look like Lydia's hairstyle
all right we're just gonna keep playing
with it and add some different prompts
all right so we asked the AI to show our
hands
uh however the hands are pretty deformed
and here we're gonna
try to fix them by using embeddings
we again go to counterfeit this model
page and we see easy negative this is
one of the textual inversion embeddings
that we can use
so the first row is with easy negative
and the second row is without looks like
easy negative does enhance the image
quality and make better hands
all right we're gonna grab those easy
negative dot safe tensors and put it in
our embeddings directory
all right going back to our web UI we're
gonna add easy negative to the negative
prompts
click on this button that shows a
portrait and under textual inversion we
have easy Necto clicking on it will
bring it into the negative prompt
all right let's do some more Generations
so what do you think do you think the
images look better with the easy
negative I think so
it looks like we got the basics of text
to image now it's time to try out image
to image
let's save this image for our use
go to the image to image Tab and upload
our image here
suppose we want a similar post but
instead of a brown hair girl we want the
pink hair girl
image to image also have batch size and
the restore faces and all the other
settings we've seen in text to image
let's hit generate
we can see that the generated images all
have similar poses to our original image
but the hair color has changed to Pink
let's add our easy negative embeddings
and try some other prompts
for example this time instead of a white
background I would like to add some
detailed backgrounds
and hit generate
all right similar poses no glosses and
with some books in the background
for other image to image options besides
uploading a picture you can also do
sketch or in paint to repair or restore
by repainting obliterated areas
this is pretty much it for the basic
usage of stable diffusion next we're
gonna cover how to train a model for a
specific character or specific art style
these models are also known as Laura
models
the internet definition for Laura is a
low rank adaptation it is a new
technique for fine-tuning deep learning
models that works by reducing the number
of trainable parameters and enables
efficient tile switching
so essentially for stable diffusion we
are patching the checkpoint models so
that the generated images will look more
like our character or art style
for this part of the tutorial we won't
need to use your logo we will be doing
everything in Google collab
we're going to use this amazing tutorial
on Civic AI to train our Laura
it's worth noting that since Google
collab is an online collaborative
service and the maintainer might need to
modify or update some of the code inside
the notebook
it will be perfectly normal if your
notebook doesn't look like mine or you
run into some errors I didn't run into
during recording this tutorial
in that case reaching out to this
maintainer on the Civic AI post might
help
cool time to take a look at the data set
requirements
for you to be able to train your Laura
you will need
anything between 20 up to a thousand
images of your desired character or art
style
also your images should have some
diversity if all of them are close-up
shots of the face your model will have a
hard time generating the whole body
feel free to read the tutorial
thoroughly in your free time but I'm
gonna just jump straight to copying The
Notebook
here is The Notebook that we just copied
I'm gonna put down Lydia as the product
name because I want to be able to
generate a model specifically for learn
to call RPG's protagonist Lydia
and when we run this Cell It's Gonna
prompt us to connect to our Google Drive
so that it could read our training
images
and in the cell you can decide whether
to grab images from the Internet or to
upload them to your Google Drive so you
can read them in from your Google home
app
here in your Google Drive you can see
that the first step of the Google collab
notebook created a Laura folder and
inside it there is your project
Lydia and we're gonna upload our
training images to this data set folder
I have 13 or 14 images generated by Ai
and when I was creating a tutorial
Quincy asked whether I think there will
be an in-breeding effect if
the AI is consuming images generated
also by AI but I think we'll be okay
I'm just gonna give it a few minutes for
the upload to be complete and now we're
ready to curate our data set
here is a cell titled cure your images
it will help you eliminate duplicates
from your training set however I know
that my training set doesn't have any
duplicates so I will skip this part
all right this next cell will use some
AI tools to help us tag our images in
other words to generate those keywords
we'll be using as the text prompt
so like for those Lydia's images we
might expect tags like brown hair short
hair green eyes one girl solo face
focused and so on
once this AI Auto tagging is complete
the next step will help us curate our
attacks
This Global activation tag will help
identify our lower model when we are
using a base stable diffusion model
when we're putting the activation tag in
the text prompt the stable diffusion
based model will know to generate
characters or art style that's specific
to our Laura
let's wait for these cells to finish and
take a look at the results
here are the top 50 tags from our
training set so we see one girl solo
brown hair green eyes all those tags
that we expect
now we run this carrier TAG cell to add
this Global activation tag to our many
text
we are basically ready to go when we
look at the extras we can analyze the
text and if we look at it we should be
able to see our Global activation tags
as well as the other tags we identified
earlier
just like for the last notebook in the
project name we're gonna put in Lydia
and we can inspect some of the training
parameters for example you get a base
training model but you can also use your
own if you don't like the default
and there is activation tag which is the
global activation tag that we put in
earlier
but before we can run this notebook we
need to close the other notebook and not
just close we need to delete the runtime
too this is because Google collab
wouldn't let you run more than one
runtime if you are using the free
version
so we go back to our data set maker
notebook interrupt any execution that
might still be happening and manage
runtime and delete this one
now we can return to our training
notebook there is one additional
parameters that we need to think about
which is the training steps
this will determine how long you will
train your model for
let's look at some guidelines from the
original stupid AI post
the guide is saying that too few steps
will undercut The Lure and make it
useless and too many will overcook it
and distort your images so we're gonna
find a balance between these
in this notebook It also says that your
image will repeat this number of times
during training I recommend your images
multiplied the by their repeat is
between 200 and 400 so since we have
like 13 images
we're gonna slightly increase the number
of repeats
and instead of saving every airport
we're gonna save every two epochs
let's leave all the other parameters as
default and start running the training
training might take some time depending
on your configurations my model took
like 20 something minutes to train and I
will speed up the process just for you
all right now we see step 100 done our
model is fully trained
inside Lydia output we see multiple
models ending in safe tensors
the number indicates the number of
epochs the model has been training for
now comes the fun part of evaluating our
model by generating some images
let me take some time to explain the
customizations I put into web UI
user.show
as we mentioned before generates a
public URL exformers according to the
docs will increase the performance on
certain Hardware
clean dark because I prefer Dark theme
to The Light theme
and the vae path and also no half VA is
to prevent some floating Point errors
all right now we launch the web UI and
wait for it to give us the public URL
now the web UI is already as usual we
put in our easy negative embeddings
then let's first try the Laura that has
been trained for eight epochs
all right the results are looking pretty
decent without any other prompts the
Laura has captured Lydia's some
character traits for example
um short brown hair
and uh green eyes
however we can do better as you may
remember from our training we're putting
an activation keyword and now let's put
in the activation keyboard to see if
that help guides the lower model even
better
all right now we got the results you
might notice that there are a lot of
half body Images instead of the more
diverse full body ones we saw with the
previous prompt before we added the FCC
Lydia keyword this might be because our
training set has a lot of half body
images and that's what this model
selected for
if you are doing your own character
remember to have some diversity in your
20 set poses
all right now let's try the model that
has been trained for 10 epochs to see if
there is any major difference
the results are not significantly
different but do notice that in one of
the images we get some hint of some
glasses without us having to enter the
glasses as part of the tags
now let's try adding a lot more text and
being more specific with the model to
see if it generates more detailed images
all right now the results have a lot
more resemblance to Lydia
well in lurgical RPG Lydia worked at a
cafe as a barista while she was also
learning how to code on the site so
let's change up the background to see if
we can make Lydia barista
so Cafe and Barista outfit and the April
all right looks like we might be missing
the classes so let's try again
we can also change our base model so
that we get a completely different base
art style I have another one and we can
give that one a try too
all right now the model is fully loaded
let's click the generate button
well this open EG model is supposed to
mimic the style of an easy Journey which
is used by mid-journey so it looks like
it has a more vibrant art style which
people might enjoy better
feel free to experiment with different
base models and see which one you like
the most
next we can try adding more loros and
generate more complex images
navigate back to the Civic website that
we have open and we can see that besides
those checkpoint models there are some
lower models and if we click on those
sample images they have the generation
data there they have the text prompt
negative prompts and simpler number of
steps Etc these generation data are a
really good reference and especially if
you copy the seed to you should be able
to get an image very similar to the
sample images
it's no guarantee that they're going to
be exactly the same but they should be
very similar
alright let's find some Laura to use
with the lower models that we have
already trained
for example I like this Laura model
which is trained on black and white
manga images and they should give you
images a manga like style if you copy
their trigger words
let's download it and put it in our
models Laura folder
now on my web Eli if I refresh I should
be able to see the anime line art manga
like
model
and let's add it to our prompt
we need to add the trigger words too
which are line art and monochrome
alright we can see that now our images
look like black and white Manga style
that's pretty cool
in the next part we are gonna cover how
to use control net to gain more fine
grain control of your image generation
here is the GitHub page of the control
net web UI plugin
control net actually gives you
fine-tuning power over your images you
can fill in your line art with AI
generated colors you could just scribble
and let AI fill in the rest for you or
you could even control the pose of
characters in your picture
let's scroll through this page and get
to the installation parts
follow the installation steps and if you
run into any security warnings you might
need to add enable insecure extension
access to your webuser.show and then
restart web UI and try the installation
after installation just follow these
steps and download the models you need
and put them in the correct folder
once you've done this it's time to go
back to the web UI and try out the
control net plugin
alright so when you expanded the control
net plugin looks like this there's an
area from two drag and drop images and
there are several parameters that you
could set
so I'm going to turn on low vram and
also just enable the control net plugin
Pixel Perfect
and I have two models I have a scribble
and a line art
let's redo our text prompt both the text
prompt and the control net
parameter setting will affect how the
images turn out
cool so I'm gonna connect to my tablet
and just draw something really random on
those canvas and see what we can
generate from there
oh don't play too much bets on my
drawing skill
I'm just gonna roughly draw a person
it's really hard to use the provided pen
tool so
yeah this is the head those are the eyes
and the body
oh I hope control net and the amazing AI
is going to help me fix my drawing
well I'm being totally unnecessary here
but I'm gonna draw some ribbons
and they of course don't even look like
ribbons
well we can see that the generated
images basically followed all the line
artwork I did
and building some pretty amazing looking
colors
it's actually pretty impressive and they
even got the ribbons right
well that was for the scribble model now
let's use some real line art and try the
lineup model as well
so I do have some promotional artwork I
did for learn to go RPG so let's try it
now let's configure our text prompt
we'll do the regular easy negative for
the negative prompts
then pick a sampling method
and we want the same to be a cafe
what the line to be a softer
and detailed
you might have noticed that we actually
didn't put in any request for people to
be in the image we'll see what a general
image actually has people in it or not
and this time we do the lineup model
so because we didn't ask for any people
to be in the artwork we are only getting
images of the cafe background looks like
I guess we need to explicitly put in two
girls in a prompt
and it looks like this time we are
getting girls in the images
looks like AI has filled in colors for
our line art
so that was the result of the lidar
model the colors are a little bit weird
so let's give the AI some more freedom
and use the scribble one instead
well now the AI has full freedom to
imagine the faces of the two girls and
looks like the results are pretty decent
the images are in square but our line
art
original picture is in the Square so
let's fix up the
aspect ratio
again with the scribble model let's
generate some more images
so yeah on the left is my original line
art and looks like the AI have generated
something that looks pretty vibrant
color
these actually look pretty good I'm very
impressed
all right besides control net there are
some other really powerful plugins or
extensions maintained by other open
source contributors
I'm gonna show you where to find those
so on the Wiki page of the stable
diffusion UI get repository we see a
page for extensions
for example this one looks like it works
with control net
and this vram estimator will allow you
to
increase dimensions of your image and
batch size until you run out of memory
so you can maximize your vram usage
this one will allow you to draw some
poses
this one says it will Target an area to
selectively enhance details
this one I've seen a lot of people use
to generate videos
and it works with the control net
extension tube
this one will help you fine-tune where
your Laura is acting on in the image
this theme seems to be showing you a
custom thumbnail view of your Laura
model
this one is for localization
this one is for editing posts I'm just
scrolling through it's a long list just
to see what kind of core effects we can
have
this one converts your images into pixel
art style looks pretty cool
this one use Transformer models to
generate text prompts for you
another pixel art
and other effects too
another prompt generator
this one saves intermediate images while
the AI is trying hard to generate them
there's even this one that will
automatically remove backgrounds and
leave only the central figures
yeah so there are lots and lots of those
extensions out there there's a lot for
you to explore we can't possibly cover
everything in a single course
and people also create their own plugins
and extensions as they see their new
device
moving on let's talk about generating
images using the stable diffusion API
there is this API Doc Page on the stable
diffusion repository website
and to enable the API we need to turn on
dash dash API in our web UI user.shell
we can see that there are several
endpoints for example the text to image
API endpoint image to image API endpoint
and when we scroll down we see sample
payload
we're just put in our prompt and number
of steps and other parameters in the
payload and it will be exactly the same
as if we were using the web UI itself
so the idea is that we send the
parameter payload to the web UI API
endpoint
using a post method and then we will
retrieve some bytes that we can decode
into our image
below the developers have provided us
with some simple python called snippet
that we can use to query the endpoint
and get our images and save it as the
output.png
all right let's grab those code snippet
and run it locally
all right for now I'm just going to copy
paste it and run it directly and I will
talk through the code in a little bit
once we see the output
just know for now that our payload is a
simple puppy dog
if we don't have some of the modules
installed that we have to import we need
to install them using pip
and just run python3 sd.py and wait for
it to finish now it looks like it has
finished and we have an output.png file
which is a puppy
all right let's try some different props
foreign we can add negative prompts into
the payload too
we're on the file again and see what we
are gonna get
oh it looks pretty futuristic and really
cool
of course we could append our alarm
modeling to it and see if we can get
Lydia generated
foreign
because we have increased the number of
steps
and we have a picture of Lydia
the last five minutes of the video is
like a bonus part
we're gonna use PostNet which is an app
for us to test out API endpoints
we are going to look at how the images
is represented in the API response
and we'll also take a deep dive into the
python code and walk through it line by
line
this is the postman app we're going to
put in our request URL there
which is the text to image endpoint and
we're going to use the post method
make sure the body is Json Raw
and click
send
so we get this long string representing
our images
and then in the response we could see
some other parameters that we don't need
to pay too much attention to
I searched for some base64 to image
decoder online
and we'll see what it works or not
all right
remove the quotes
remove the starting quilt two
and here's our image
now let's walk through this python file
line by line
so here we're doing a bunch of imports
we imported Json we imported requests
for making a post request and we import
a base64 for decoding and we imported
some image libraries
and we set our URL to be the public
instance that our web UI is running on
and we create our payload just like this
and then we post to our URL and the
specific API endpoint which is text to
image given the payload and I get the
response convert it to Json
and remember the images field that we
saw that's our image string so we decode
it into an image
this part here is retrieving some
metadata for the PNG for example what
parameters are used to generate a PNG
Etc and finally we save this image
alongside with this PNG info it's pretty
straightforward
feel free to play with the code on your
own you can also make API requests in
other programming languages of your
choice
all right as promised in case you don't
have access to a GPU here are some ways
you can run stable diffusion on some
free online platforms
of course there is going to be
restrictions like you won't have access
to all the models you want you won't be
able to upload your custom model and the
other people on the internet are also
using the servers so you could be in the
queue for a long time before your images
are generated
here we are on hugging face and we will
go through spaces
and in the search bar we type in stable
diffusion
and let's sort by most number of likes
so looks like the most popular one is
the one by stability AI which happened
to be the original one so this will be
the best option however it shows that it
is passed so I don't think you'll be
able to use it
let's take a look at the other ones that
we have access to
of course these online models might be
limited in that it doesn't have the base
model you want it doesn't have the style
that you want but this is the best we
can do if we don't have access to a
local GPU
foreign
s are a little distorted so maybe the
space model isn't great for generating
anime images
and that's one of its limitations
looking through the list we see some
image to image some in paintings some
photo generic one I think we'll be using
the photo generic one
let's give it a shot
now this one looks like the stable
diffusion standard web UI that we're
used to
and we can see that it's currently live
and running on an online GPU
they say the model is a protogen
which should be a photorealism model
foreign
looks like they are restraining the
number of images we can generate
but let's do it
and also we will have to wait in the
queue
so yeah
if you don't like to wait or if you
really need to use your custom models
you should consider getting your own GPU
all right finally after waiting for
almost five minutes I got my result back
it looks pretty good
and with that we'll conclude today's
tutorial I hope you enjoyed it and I
hope to see you in the next video